[Applause]
a children's fun day held in the memory
of a child who can't be here
star hobson's family do what they can to
remember the joy she brought
but the pain doesn't go away
i wake up on the morning it's first i
just first thing i think of is star
i don't think we'll ever no i don't i
really don't i can't i'm struggling to
get there's just no words for how much
it has ruined our whole family
star hobson was killed by her mother's
lover savannah brockhill also jailed for
causing or allowing star's death was her
mother frankie smith the family don't
forgive smith but say brock hill was a
malign influence who isolated frankie
and her daughter
so much that frankie's sister alicia
resorted to sneaking over to her sister
and niece when brock hill was working
night shifts savannah was at work and
i'd sleep over with frankie and stan all
them videos that you they're from
frankie's flat that's where so i
actually had a lot of nice memories in
that flat well you know before obviously
what happened
i'm coming by
yet alicia's visits were probably star's
happiest times too
he was spoiled pretty good
she was a different child when with
savannah brockhill and it would emerge
that out of sight she was being tortured
and beaten
from prison her mother frankie told
david that she was about to leave brock
hill she told savannah that was it
yeah i'm done and frankie
has even said i think she did that
because i were leaving her and it was
the only way she could get at me
she didn't like anybody who was anybody
do you think star was kind of revenge
for yeah yeah i don't yeah yeah she
thought well how can i get up if i can't
have you you can't have her she knew
what she what she were doing
it wasn't just a spur-of-the-moment
thing
star do you love your mums frankie smith
didn't make this case in court and she
too was found responsible for cruelty
and neglect
five times the wider family including
alicia and david reported concerns to
social services complete with images
showing stars bruising i know social
workers do have a lot of cases and you
know and it's hard and but it's like if
you are going to that job it's like the
social workers that i dealt with to do
with star it seemed to me like they
weren't really that bothered what
happened to star will form part of a
national review due to be published
tomorrow which aims to protect at-risk
children in the future
jason farrell sky news